normalmente las protestas de activistas
y Defensores de los derechos humanos y
del medio ambiente son una constante en
estas Cumbres climáticas y se realizan
libremente en las calles de la ciudad
anfitriona Egipto que ostenta la
presidencia de la 27 y que organiza este
evento impuso fuertes restricciones para
poder llevar a cabo estas marchas de
protesta avisar con 36 o 48 horas de
antelación dar información de contacto o
la descripción de los temas a abordar en
las marchas son algunos de los
requisitos que Egipto le está exigiendo
a las organizaciones el espacio
originalmente designado por la cop 27
para estas marchas está en esta llamada
zona verde a 20 minutos a pie de la zona
donde se llevan las negociaciones aunque
también se puede acceder con un autobús
gratuito sin embargo he preguntado a
varias personas aquí y ninguno sabe de
este área específica para hacer
manifestaciones sin embargo y por eso al
no fiarse de que se respeten los
derechos de los asistentes la mayoría de
los grupos ha decidido manifestarse
dentro de la llamada zona azul donde se
lleva acabo las negociaciones que está
regida por las Naciones Unidas y tiene
su propia seguridad un ambiente lejos de
ser ideal y que refleja la situación o
la ubicación de esta ciudad en la que
estamos armelsake una urbe rodeada por
un lado del mar rojo y por otro
encerrada por un muro finalizado en 2021
de 36 kilómetros una ciudad a la que
para acceder por carretera hay que pasar
por una de las cuatro puertas existentes
equipadas con escáneres y cámaras y una
ciudad a la que los propios egipcios
deben entrar con un permiso especial ya
sea de trabajo o de residencia